So, notice that in both cases, we're finding the distance between two points,
here and here, and here and here. When we found the distance between these two
points, we set up a right triangle and found the horizontal distance between
them, and the vertical distance between them. This allowed us to use the
Pythagorean Theorem to find the hypotenuse or the diagonal between the two
points. The same was true in this case for town 2. We found the distance
horizontally between the mile markers. And then the distance vertically, or
south to go to the town. We squared these two numbers and found their sum, and
then took the square root to get the distance. We can do something similar if
we wanted to find the distance between any two points. So, let's say we had
these points, negative 7 and 3, and 5 and 8. We can think of drawing two
interstates our roads, horizontally and vertically. And the distance between
the two points is the diagonal, or the hypotenuse of the right triangle we just
created. To find the vertical distance between the two points, we want to look
at the y values. We can think about this vertical distance as starting at y
equals 3. Then it goes all the way up to y equals 8. So, if we find the
difference, or the amount between the y values, we'll get the vertical
distance, which is 5 here. So, knowing this, what do you think would be the
horizontal distance? What's this distance?